in a world divided by fear one man must
stand alone against the forces of
darkness from the studio that
inexplicably showed his [ __ ] mouth
shut the first time comes five-time
Academy Award viewer Ryan Reynolds as a
man on an eHarmony date with destiny
ladies and gentlemen I give you big
Deadpool so get ready to blow out your
collective sphincters cuz my trailer is
coming why the fancy red suit mr. pool
oh that's because it's christmas day
dopinder and i'm after someone on my
naughty list
you're probably thinking this was a
superhero movie but that guy in the suit
just turned that other guy into a
[ __ ] kebab surprise this is a
different kind of superhero story to
tell it right we got to take you back
before I squeezed this ass in spandex
mr. Wilson you've recently been
diagnosed with terminal cancer we can
fight this
what if I told you we can cure you and
give you abilities most men only dream
of I'd say that you sound like an
infomercial but not a good one like Slap
Chop more shake weighty if I never see
you again
know that I love you when I'm finished
it mutates its cells will heal anything
but you still think we're making you a
superior we're making you a super same
oh come on you're gonna leave me all
alone here with Jose Canseco whatever
they did to me made me totally
indestructible and completely no
unfuckable you you look like the inside
of other people's [ __ ] I didn't ask
to be super and I'm no hero but when you
find out your worst enemy is after your
best girl the time has come to be a
[ __ ] superhero
we can't allow this Deadpool I don't
have time for your x-men [ __ ]
Colossus besides nobody's getting hurt
that guy was up there before we got here
I played a lot of roles damsel in
distress they wanna time to make the
chimi [ __ ] chunga's have you seen
this man
I never say this but don't swallow did I
leave the stove on you're way too much
dude for me
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet that's fine just give
us a second go get her tiger so pity the
dude who pressures her into prom sex hi
Deadpool here with an important public
service announcement this is your brain
actually it's a chimichanga but I'm
making a point because this is your
brain on IMAX bigger is better right I
love you Wade Wilson we can fight this
you're right the cancer is only my liver
lungs prostate and brain all things I
can live without
what if I told you we can make you
better
you're a fighter we can give you
abilities most men only dream of make
you a superhero would you just promise
you'll do right by me so I can do right
by someone else and please don't make
the supersuit green or animated one
thing that never survives this place
it's a sense of humor we'll see about
that posh spice oh come on you know
leave me all alone here with less angry
Rosie O'Donnell I wanna thank your
mother
wait you may be wondering why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants daddy needs to
express some rage no difference
girl
enemy better how many kids up
it reeks like old lady pants in here
sounds like you have a dick in your
mouth Oh [ __ ] you are hard to
look at like a testicle with teeth look
like Freddy Krueger face-fucked a
topographical map of Utah
exactly
stay out of my way
oh I'm touching myself tonight look like
an avocado had sex with an older avocado
thank you hi I'm Deadpool the other
jolly guy in a red suit with a Lapworth
sitting on here to tell you happy
holidays and the spirit of this most
festive time of year I've decided to
release my holiday cheer all over the
world
how you ask well you naughty stocking
stuffers brace yourselves because
starting today you're getting not one
not two but twelve glorious days of
Deadpool so sit back hold on your
ornaments guzzle a little eggnog at
least that looks like eggnog and prepare
yourself because it's time for Saint
Wade to put the wind in winter
wonderland
Deadpool in theaters February 12 Torsten
like before Christmas and a good guy in
red hunting down bad guys why the red
suit well that's so bad guys can't see
me bleed this guy's got the right idea
he wore the brown pants let's recap they
messed with his face and kidnapped his
girl is not used to be in the hero
nobody's getting hurt
Merry Christmas
this was the week before Christmas in
all around town bball fans were dying to
watch LeBron Steph and Russell's row
down she bring back the short shorts who
wears short shorts I do I wear shorts a
basketball miracle right here on
Christmas Day stuff to do our stockings
by the Jolly NBA join us for games who
want something else cool in between all
the dunks a sneak peek of Deadpool I
hope you've been nice
see you on Christmas boys and girls who
are you talking to you may be wondering
why I brought you here at some point we
was all joined forces become a team now
how many of you have taken a human life
what goodness
two socks the hell's your name Ray Bans
come here
all right Stevie Wonder what's your
superpower that's the stupidest
superpower ever heard you're not on the
team I'm kidding you're on the team
you're not on the team
sit back over there now what does this
suit look like to you huh does it look
like a leprechaun had sex with a
cartoonist the steep drop in 220 storm
come here what's your superpower you can
control the weather like Al Roker how
many fingers am i holding up trick
question zero get back in this way
we're gonna fight crime maybe start a
little crime I really wish we could sew
his mouth shut again we're gonna get out
there we're gonna kick a little ass this
is the magical x-men oh one two three
okay guys team photo
dad why the fancy red suit mr. pool when
a dude tries to make you a super slave
and kidnaps your future baby mama the
time has come to be super heroic share
the music
I only have ten bullets so you're gonna
have to share
I am very turned on right now love is
the Colossus nobody's getting hurt was
up there before we got here cool good
why the fancy red suit mr. pool oh
that's because it's christmas day
dopinder and i'm after someone on my
naughty list you're probably thinking
this was a superhero movie but that guy
in the suit just turned that other guy
into a kebab surprise this is a
different kind of superhero story to
tell it right we got to take you back
before I squeezed into red spandex mr.
Wilson you've recently been diagnosed
with terminal cancer we can fight this
what if I told you we can cure you and
give you abilities most men only dream
of I'd say that you sound like an
infomercial but not a good one like Slap
Chop more shake weighty if I never see
you again
know that I love you when I'm finished
the mutated cells will heal anything but
you still think we're making you a
superior we're making you a super same
come on you gonna leave me all alone
here with Jose Canseco
whatever they did to me made my body
indestructible but my face oh look at me
I know look at it now I don't want it
exactly I didn't ask to be super and I'm
no hero
but when you find out your worst enemy
is after your best girl the time has
come to be a superhero cue the music
we can't allow this Deadpool I don't
have time for x-men pull Colossus
besides nobody's getting hurt that guy
was up there before we got here we're
gonna put a lot of rules damsel in
distress they wanna
have you seen this man
wait did I leave the stove on no give it
to you yeah you're way too much dude for
me that's why I brought down
I mean that's why I brought her oh no
finish your tweet go get her tiger
so pity the dude who pressures her into
prom sex Bob surprise this is a
different kind of superhero story to
tell it right
we got to take you back before I
squeezed this ass into spandex this